nach zusammen herzlich willkommen bei
zdf heute live ihre mit eurem live
stream zu aktuellen diskussionen und
ereignissen und da gibt es gerade eine
große diskussion um den impfstoff von
astrazeneca die einen sagen der ist
sicher der ist geprüft und den kammern
ohne probleme verenden
andere sagen aber den risiken und
nebenwirkungen sind uns zu hoch das
können wir oder wollen wir nicht
akzeptieren was stimmt jetzt und wie
steht die ständige impfkommission dazu
die diesen impfstoff ja zumindest mit
einigen aus mit einigen einschränkungen
genehmigt hat das wollen wir heute
klären wird professor thomas sie ist
vizepräsidentin der deutschen
gesellschaft für allgemeinmedizin und
familienmedizin und mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission des robert koch
instituts hallo herr professor thomas
guten abend es gibt eine große
diskussion um diesen impfstoff können
sie die nachvollziehen
wirklich ehrlich gesagt nicht weil bei
allen stoffen die in deutschland
zugelassen bekannt ist dass sie in
gleicher weise häufig in kreationen
machen das heißt das was jetzt so viel
geschrieben wird von dem astra zeneca
impfstoff dass menschen sich kann schön
in den tagen danach und eine
grippeähnliche symptome entwickeln das
ist er vorher bekannt gewesen war so
erwartet dass die beiden anderen stoffe
dann genau so dass da ja aber da sind
doch weniger nebenwirkungen und die
wirksamkeit jetzt ja auch ein
unterschied was ist denn da in der
kommunikation in ihren augen schief
gelaufen
naja vielleicht die diskussion um die
wirksamkeit und die diskussion darum
dass dieses nun ein schlechterer
impfstoff sei was nicht stimmt es sind
zu allen drei impfstoffen haben studien
stattgefunden und da sind etwas
unterschiedliche werte für diese
sogenannte ineffektivität rausgekommen
das wird auch immer falsch interpretiert
übrigen wenn ein impfstoff eine
effektivität hat von 40 prozent dann
bedeutet das nicht dass 30 prozent nicht
geschützt werden sondern dass das
risiko in einem bestimmten kontext und
das war der komplex in diese studien
stattgefunden zu haben
zu erkranken in der gruppe diesen
impfstoff bekommen hat um 70 prozent
gesenkt wurde
andere teilen und der war in der tat bei
astrazeneca studien das waren mehrere
studien im mittel etwa 70 prozent und
weit in amerika impfstoffen seitens
effektivität im mittel etwa zu sehr als
90 prozent wurde das ist kein direkter
vergleich diese habe ich auch ja gruppen
bei dem astra zeneca impfstoff wo ja
auch sehr hoch war und im prinzip ist es
widert halbfinale beim fußball da könnt
ihr auch hinterher noch nicht sagen wer
meister wird wenn sie gucken wer da die
meisten tore geschossen hat solange der
direkte vergleich nicht stattgefunden
hat so dass wahrscheinlich die
unterschiede da nicht so groß sind
das ist ein sehr schönes bild damit
können wahrscheinlich viele was anfangen
wir haben auch noch mal versucht das
ganze auseinander zu drosseln weil es
ist zugegebenermaßen nicht so einfach zu
verstehen wenn man keinen medizinischen
hintergrund hat mein kollege jan
friedrich fischer hat das noch mal
versucht kurz und kompakt wir uns
zusammen zu fassen geht es um impfstoffe
wird der begriff wirksamkeit oft falsch
verstanden
beispiel astrazeneca das anti corona
mittel hat nach bisherigen erkenntnissen
eine wirksamkeit von rund 60 prozent
manche glauben nun von zehn personen
können immer noch vier erkranken
trotz impfung das stimmt so nicht
stattdessen wird mit dem begriff
wirksamkeit das risiko zweier
unterschiedlichen studiengruppen
verglichen in diesem fall einer gruppe
mit und einer ohne impfstoff beispiel
während in der gruppe der nicht
geimpften 80 von 100 personen erkranken
sind jetzt in der anderen nur 32 unterm
strich ergibt dies unter den geimpften
personen 60 prozent weniger fälle also
da arbeiten wir mit wahrscheinlichkeiten
und mit prozentzahlen da haben viele in
der schule war irgendwann mal was davon
mitbekommen aber ja so richtig weiß man
auch nicht mehr was das heißt das heißt
wenn ich mir diese wahrscheinlichkeit
angucke die 60-prozentige
wahrscheinlichkeit dann würden sie sagen
dass es trotzdem immer noch eine
ausreichend hohe schutz
das ist immer noch ein guter schutz
empfehlung der whu und welche praxis ist
dass wir sachen impfstoff der eine
wirksamkeit von 50 prozent oder mehr hat
der als das erkrankungsrisiko halbiert
er sollte zugelassen werden und 70
prozent ist das was ein grippeimpfstoff
jahre leisten kann
da habe ich mal einfach anleihen frage
weil wir sind ja hier die wenigsten sind
vom fach die sich damit beschäftigen
warum wirken diese impfstoffe eigentlich
unterschiedlich also ich stelle mir das
eben als laie vor da gibt es diese diese
diesen impfstoff der gegeben wird da
sind bestimmte körper drin
wie kann es sein dass die so große
unterschiede haben
na ja beide oder alle drei impfstoffe
sorgen dafür dass der eigene körper
dieses protein den pickel auf den corona
virus herstellt und antikörper dagegen
bildet die art und weise wie ein körper
eingebracht wird ist etwas
unterschiedlich und daraus könnte man
sich schon vorstellen dass eine
unterschiedliche wirksamkeit entsteht
dass der eine impfstoff vielleicht gar
nicht so vollständig in die zelle
gelangte der andere das tut aber was ich
vorhin schon sagte ist das sicher
genauso große wahrscheinlichkeit ist
dass es einfach an unterschieden in den
studien populationen lag also an
vorherigen eigenschaften die die
mitgebracht haben das heißt auch weil
die auswahl der studien teilnehmer innen
gar nicht ja so vergleichbar ist das
sind verschiedene altersklassen
verschiedene menschen einfach lässt sich
das kann ich meinen sie behaupten der
länder verschiedene gar nicht
vergleichen eigentlich man kann
zumindest nicht wo direkt vergleichen
dass man diese zahlen so als ganz stark
dastehen etwas auch noch es ist zum teil
etwas unterschiedliche fall definitionen
heißt ob man in einer studie hinterher
angekreuzt hat diese person war erkrankt
oder noch wichtiger diese person war
schwer erkrankt wurde etwas
unterschiedlich definiert das heißt da
kommen auch wieder etwas
unterschiedliche zahlen heraus dass
meine ich damit wenn ich sage dass die
unterschiede in
wirksamkeit zahlen aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach überbewertet
sind aber nichtsdestotrotz als laie wenn
ich höre ein wirkstoff hat eine
95-prozentige wirksamkeit dann habe ich
das gefühl der ist das der bessere den
bevorzuge ich also würde ich lieber den
nehmen als den anderen das können sie
nachvollziehen oder nicht clapper nicht
ab nach folgten
das problem ist wird das wird diese
auswahl gar nicht haben und das im
moment tatsächlich darum geht den ein-
oder nämlich den anderen würden nämlich
den ich kriegen kann
und das ist wichtig das ist wichtig denn
dann zu nehmen
um selber geschützt seien als auch auf
die gesamte bevölkerung betrachtet es
dafür zu sorgen dass eben möglichst
schnell menschen geschützt sind und dass
wir uns insbesondere mit schweren
verlaufsformen erreichen kann aber sich
auch wahrscheinlich nicht mehr ganz so
weiter verbreiten kann
von daher ja ist es wirklich sehr
bedauerlich werden das so interpretiert
wird
dann hast du fragen prüfen sie ihren
blutdruck tabletten eigentlich laut so
genau
oder sagen sie da das kann man am besten
auch schon aber nichtsdestotrotz hat
südafrika zb die vergabe dieses
impfstoffes gestoppt weil es den
verdacht dass der gegen die dortige
virus mutation nicht so wirksam sein
soll
finden sie dass da nicht richtig jeder
kündigt ich das ist eine ganz komische
geschichte was die südafrikaner da getan
haben wir haben eine kleine studie die
sagt der impfstoff ist nicht nur wirksam
gegen leichte bis mittelschwere verkäufe
jetzt mal ehrlich wen interessieren
interessieren vielleicht aber diese
längst nicht mehr so bedeutsam
die leichten und mittelschweren verläufe
gegen schwere verläufe alten verliert
eine beratung erfordert haben oder in
den menschen gestorben bin da schützt da
nämlich sehr gut
die denselben studien und auch in den
zulassungsstudien also was auch immer
die afrikaner darf ab regieren
ich weiß es nicht und ich verstehe auch
nicht aber es gibt jetzt aufgrund dieser
vielen fragen die es gibt auch wegen der
verschiedenen wirksamkeit jetzt gemessen
wurde auch wenn sie sagen das lässt sich
nicht so wirklich vergleichen
forderungen den impfstoff nicht an alle
gleichmäßig zu spritzen auch wenn sie
gerade gesagt haben die wahl haben wir
gar nicht zum beispiel frank ulrich
montgomery der vorstandsvorsitzende dass
welt ärzte bundeswehr hat uns gerade im
interview folgendes gesagt
der liegt nicht vor der o ton oder
müssen wir das mal kurz und wir sollten
die wirksamsten impfstoffe für
diejenigen reservierten die das höchste
infektionsrisiko haben oder den
schwersten verlauf der erkrankung also
für all die alten kranken beladenen und
die die sie betreuen in der priorität
gruppe 1 den astra weniger impfstoff
sicher ist und er auch wirksam ist den
sollten wir in der realität gruppe 2 all
denen anbieten deren risiko zu erkranken
viel geringer ist und bei denen auch das
risiko schwerer verläufe nicht so
ausgeprägt ist also herr montgomery sagt
der stoff ist sicher aber er würde ihn
eher nicht an menschen geben die ein
höheres risiko haben zu erkranken finden
sie das richtig frau professor ich das
tun wir ja auch nicht für eine politik
wird ja genau das gemacht oder fast
genau das gemacht was herr montgomery
vorgeschlagen hatte nämlich die
impfstoffe werden für alte menschen
eingesetzt die mit abstand das höchste
risiko schwerer erkrankungen uns alles
angucken 19 haben das alter und zwar
jede lebensdekade oberhalb der 60 ist
eine erhebliche bedeutung risikofaktor
als alle vorerkrankungen abweichen ist
die entwicklung aber jetzt und viele
länder haben das auch in eine verordnung
garten viele bundesländer die
betreuenden personen die in aller regel
unter 65 sind eben mit dem astra zeneca
impfstoff impfen weil der schnell diese
gruppe verfügbar ist während während der
die marinade stoffe insbesondere der
biotech impfstoff und moderner gibt es
im moment hier noch weniger eben nicht
in ausreichender menge zur verfügung
steht um diese große erste priorität
gruppe vollständig abdecken zu können
aber genau ist aber genau in dieser
gruppe gibt es ja diskussion darum ob
das tatsächlich so eine gute idee ist
wir haben wir ein kleines stück von
unserem kollegen peter kunst er hat sich
mit diesen
neben selbst beschäftigt deswegen ja
viele oder einige pflegende und
beschäftigte in den medizinischen
berufen jetzt sorge haben ob sie sich
diesen impfstoff tatsächlich spritzen
lassen wollen wir gucken uns das stück
von herrn kunst mal an boris johnson und
astrazeneca der britisch-schwedische
impfstoff ist der stolz des
premierministers mit dem er auf den
britischen inseln tempo beim impfen
macht ohne große probleme mit diesem
vakzin ohne vorübergehenden stopps wie
zum beispiel in braunschweig im herzogin
elisabeth krankenhaus wurde personal wm
fast die hälfte davon fiel dann erst mal
aus mit fieber und grippesymptome
das hat mich echt keinen dank gehört wir
haben natürlich nicht so einen hohen
anteil an nebenwirkungen erwartet wir
haben etwa zehn prozent erwartet wie die
studienlage es hergibt astrazeneca
reagiert gegenüber dem zdf
derzeit sind die gemeldeten reaktionen
so wie wir sie aufgrund der erkenntnisse
aus unserem klinischen studienprogramm
erwarten würden
dazu gehören vorübergehende lokale
reaktionen wie kopfschmerzen
schüttelfrost fieber
die reaktionen traten häufiger einen tag
nach der impfung auf astrazeneca in
deutschland empfohlen bis zum alter von
64 jahren hat mit 70 prozent einen
geringeren wirkungsgrad als andere
impfstoffe weniger nutzen näher
beschwerden so sagt auch im krankenhaus
mancher nein zu dieser info und was
passiert es ist mir einfach zu hoch für
den schutz den wir am endeffekt haben
lieber einen geringen schutz als gar
keinen schutz war der mangel an dem
stoff den wir im moment haben würde ich
immer noch empfehlen sich mit
astrazeneca impfen zu lassen
der bundesgesundheitsminister war beute
für vertrauen in fraktionen sind
übrigens ja erst mal durchaus kein
schlechtes zeichen sie zeigen dass das
immunsystem reagiert
auch in braunschweig wird jetzt nur noch
geimpft wer danach dienstfrei oder
wochenende hat um mögliche
impfreaktionen auszukurieren
tja pro frau frau professor hungers
ständige mitglied mitglied in der
ständigen impfkommission am rki ist die
zweite rede und antwort wenn wir gerade
gehört haben das sind so viele menschen
aus der belegschaft dann tatsächlich mit
impfreaktionen ausgefallen dann muss man
auch sagen das ganze war eher
kontraproduktiv oder das ist das zeichen
dass der körper der geimpften personen
schnell darauf reagiert und eine abwehr
entwickelt das ist eigentlich sogar ein
gutes zeichen
darum drücken dass auch bei ihren
kompetenten gehören menschen häufiger
auf als bei den älteren lehrern den
altenheimen den anderen impfstoffen ist
das nicht so auch betreten das liegt
aber nicht gestoppt sondern an den
personen
ich weiß nicht woher der kollege vorhin
die studierenden nimmt in den studien
die ich gelesen habe da steht dass alle
drei impfstoffe auch sehr von
astrazeneca in über der hälfte der fälle
jedem impfreaktionen macht es darf daher
auch durchaus die überlegung auch in ihr
bekannten kontexten hier eben nicht das
ganze personal auf einmal zu impfen und
bringen gab es auch die nebenwirkungen
die ausfälle dadurch wenn größere
personen zahlen jüngeren alters mit
bajonett impfstoff geimpft worden sind
auch da haben wir gehört wo wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir nur eine schicht auf
einmal impfen und nicht alle ein
unterschied ist dass bei den amerikanern
stoffen diese impfreaktionen vor allen
dingen nach der zweiten impfung
auftreten und bei astrazeneca impfstoff
ist es so dass sie vor allen dingen nach
der ersten impfung auftreten und beim
zweiten mal eben nicht mehr so
ausgeprägt sind werden das bei den
anderen umgekehrt ist aber in der karten
bei allen drei impfstoffen erwarb war
häufig deutlich über 50 prozent
aber eben gleich häufig ist das
eigentlich ist das ist das normal das
ist bei solchen impfungen dazu kommt
also sind wir da in der öffentlichkeit
einfach unter informiert und schauen
jetzt auf ein phänomen was ihr nicht so
richtig kennen
ja das war mal das unterscheidet sich
von impfstoff zu impfstoffe es gibt auch
andere impfstoffe die häufiger mal
reaktionen machen dazu gehört vor allen
dingen gelten stoff gegen herpes zoster
und auch der impfstoff gegen
pneumokokken vor allen dingen wieder
mehrfach eingesetzt
wird aber das sind dinge mit den älteren
menschen geimpft werden und sonst nichts
die deutsche bevölkerung durch eine
grippe oder tetanus impfung ist
verträglicher aber trotzdem sind das
normale phänomene die stehen in der
fachinformation der entsprechenden
stoffe drin
und die waren zu erwarten also ich
schaue jetzt mal unsere kommentare wir
haben natürlich auch einige fragen es
gibt auch viele kritische kommentare wir
gucken erst mal auf die fragen florian
lara möchte auf youtube wissen was
interessiert nicht fürs erste die
wirksamkeit wenn mir keiner sagen kann
wie es später ausschied mit etwaigen
folgen oder spätfolgen
zum beispiel was veränderungen was die
organe angeht et cetera
was können sie da herr mahler antworten
frau professor omas es ist ja in der tat
so dass der impfstoff wie auch die
krankheit
es gibt weit es noch nicht so furchtbar
lange wir lernen zunehmend etwas darüber
dass coop 19 ganz erhebliche spätfolgen
oder sehr schwieriger lange verläufe
haben kann
von daher sehe ich das holt so dass wir
der impfstoff etwas nützt wenn ich diese
schwere krankheit nicht bekomme und es
gibt keine sagt jetzt mit biologisch
plausible gründe anzunehmen dass der
impfstoff schwere spätfolgen haben
könnte natürlich kann man das mit
letzter sicherheit jetzt ausschließen
dass man entsprechend lang war das hat
jetzt das theologisch hochrechnen das
kann man gut beobachten und den
impfstoff gibt es jetzt seit noch nicht
ganz einem jahr die erkrankung gibt es
seit gut einem jahr
und bei beiden werden sie dazu aber es
gibt keinen nachvollziehbaren
wissenschaftliche erklärbaren grund
warum der impfstoff schlechter
verträglich sein sollte als die
erkrankung selber und manuell wirklich
hohen erkrankungsrisiko ist glaube ich
der impfstoff die bessere wahl
aber genau diese ja kurze zeitspanne
sorgt ja bei manchen auch bei manchen
zuschauern für skepsis ich habe mal
einen kommentar ausgesucht hier von uwe
mehr bach mal auf meinen rechner
schalten bitte also ich bin ganz ehrlich
schreibt er ich vertraue dem zeug nicht
die zulassungen gingen mir zu schnell
da muss man ja schon feststellen frau
professor thomas normalerweise dauert
das sehr viele jahre bis ein impfstoff
zugelassen
das ging jetzt sehr fix wie war das
möglich
bis er zugelassen ist dauert gar nicht
unbedingt sehr viele jahre aber bis er
entwickelt ist dass es in der tat jetzt
bei diesen impfstoffen sehr schnell
gegangen dass das so schnell ging hat
mehrere gründe und die wichtigsten
gründe sind eigentlich dass er in einer
welt notlage entwickelt wurde in der die
ganze welt sich mühe gegeben hat
impfstoffe zu entwickeln
das heißt da ist mit sehr sehr viel geld
sehr viel wissen und sehr viel energie
sind prozesse parallel gelaufen die man
sonst in einander schalten und probiert
man erst mal aus mit ein paar tiere dann
sagt man da und lassen sich mit wenigen
menschen und damit etwas mehr
während jetzt viel schneller die
verschiedenen entwicklungsschritte
parallel gemacht wurden während
gleichzeitig die zulassungsbehörden
immer schon die ergebnisse mit gelesen
haben während sie sonst sagen würden nun
warten sie mal ab und sammeln sie das
mal alles in ihrem stapel und reichen
dass ein wird damit fertig sind und dann
gucken wir uns das an wenn wir zeit
haben es jetzt ein bisschen schlapp sich
aber so ähnlich läuft das so
während jetzt die ganze entwicklung
parallel
der andere grund ist das ist sehr
schnell sehr viele menschen gegeben hat
die bereit waren sich an eine derartige
studie einfließen zu lassen
das sonst auch nicht so ganz einfach
weil man keinen anlass dass ich jetzt
mal neuen impfstoff auszuprobieren und
nachts angesichts sehr peinliche lage
ist eben relativ schnell
erkrankungsfälle hat das würde man bei
einer seltenen erkrankung auch nicht
haben
da muss man viel länger warten bis man
es überhaupt erkrankungsfälle hat deren
häufigkeit man vergleichen kann zwischen
den beiden gruppen von bayer hat die
pandemie tatsächlich auch die
entwicklung des wirkstoffes beschleunigt
in europa sind die ansprüche an die
zulassung nicht anders gesehen sind als
du das bei anderen impfstoffen auf sind
das hat die auflagen die studie weiter
zu führen und besonders und im
fliegenden nach zu beobachten
deswegen ja viel bürokratie mit den
ängsten verbunden ist für die
impfzentren
aber es gibt kein beschleunigtes oder
vereinfachten verfahren an der
europäischen arzneimittelagentur von
daher können sie doch unsere kunden
anzulegen
da fehlt irgendwie schlechter sind als
andere impfstoffe es geht jetzt ganz
ganz kurz es gibt beschwerden hier in
der zuschauerschaft dass ihre
tonqualität nicht so hervorragend ist
das bitte ich jetzt mal in unserem namen
zu entschuldigen wir machen das hier mal
wieder über einen großen video
konferenzanbieter
und da ist es manchmal auch so und frau
professor ist es natürlich auch keine
professionelle ich sag mal
videoproduzenten deswegen haben sie
jetzt nicht das große equipment zu hause
die sind trotzdem sehr dankbar dass die
bayern sind und ich hoffe irgendwie
können sie trotzdem gut verstehen eine
frage die immer wieder gestellt wird
wenn wir mit menschen reden die sich mit
diesen impfstoff und auskennen ist von
sabine eckert diesmal ob sie sich selber
schon haben impfen lassen
ja ich habe mich mit welchen impfstoff
ich muss zugeben ich bin mit dem
bajonett impfstoff geben das liegt daran
dass ich hier das städtische impfzentrum
pleite und somit eben sehr früh auch
bevor der astrazeneca impfstoff
zugelassen war tatsächlich schon selber
geworden bin
ich hätte aber auch den anderen genommen
gut haben wir das auch geklärt so jetzt
haben wir noch einige fragen zur
wirksamkeit wir waren ja gerade schon
bei dieser frage der südafrikanischen
mutation anita hat fragt auf facebook
wenn die sich hier ausbreitet sind wir
mit diesen impfstoff doch fast gänzlich
ungeschützt ist das nicht für alle
menschen mit vorerkrankungen sehr
gefährlich ich glaube da müssen sie noch
einmal ganz kurz darauf eingehen wenn
ich das richtig verstanden habe so
einfach lässt sich das nicht behaupten
dass hier gänzlich ungeschützt sind
richtig so bietet sicherlich
ungeschützte als wir das ohne impfstoff
sind oder umgehe im sprint das ist schon
mal ganz wichtig dass andere ist nicht
bekannt dass der impfstoff gegen
südafrikanische mutation jetzt weniger
wirksam sei oder nicht ob das stimmt
nicht aber gar nichts wirklich nein
gesagt dass afrika jetzt daran hindert
ist nicht dass der impfstoff gegen die
mutation an sich nicht sinnvoll sei
sondern dass ich sagen er verhindert
leichte erkrankung mit nicht gesucht
heißt eigentlich eher verhindert nicht
nur sehr die ansteckung dass ich als
geimpfter dritte anstecken kann darf
sagen uns wissen also die sich auskennen
das wissen wir von allen drei
impfstoffen noch nicht ob sie das tun
da wird noch auf studienergebnisse
gewartet das ist auch bei den bayern
kirche und moderner impfstoffen nicht
anders zu beschützen sag ich mal dass
die wirkung siegen die mutanten ist egal
jetzt auf brasilien südafrika
großbritannien oder die anderen dieser
zu erwarten und sie hat vielleicht
bayerischer wald oder hamburg oder köln
halten genauso gut wirken sie gegen
diese entwickelt wurde
es ist aber auch nicht anzunehmen dass
überhaupt nicht wirken und die wenigen
studien die es dazu gibt die weisen auch
darauf hin dass sie würden also mein
verständlicher sonst protein ist relativ
groß das bietet ziemlich viele
angriffsflächen auch fürs immunsystem
und selbst wenn sich das an einzelnen
stellen verändert bedeutet das sehr
wahrscheinlich nicht dass die impfstoffe
gleich gar nicht mehr wirken und damit
ist es immer noch besser den zu haben
als gar keinen
es wird vermutlich so sein dass man
impfstoffes wird nacharbeiten müssen und
danach im zug wird müssen gegen
zukünftig auftretende mutationen genau
noch ein paar fragen zum wirksamkeit von
evelyn kreuzer auf facebook war geht es
jetzt um diese altersgrenze die sie auch
bei der ständigen impfkommission gezogen
haben
ich bin verunsichert was die
tauglichkeit dieses impfstoffes von
astrazeneca angeht für chronisch kranke
die nun vorgezogen werden wenn er für
über 65-jährige nicht empfohlen wird
deren immunsystem schwächer sind dann
ist dies bei unter 65 jährigen mit
schweren vorerkrankungen schließlich
auch der fall
was können sie dazu sagen ist eine
schwierige frage was bei über 65 die ja
nicht auch da wird häufig kolportiert
der impfstoff wird dabei würde bei denen
nicht wirken
das ist äußerst unwahrscheinlich dass er
das nicht tut woher soll der impfstoff
über den sechzigsten geburtstag
informiert sein und dann hinterher nicht
mehr würden nur es waren sehr sehr
wenige menschen über 65 in studien
eingeschlossen von astrazeneca
das liegt wahrscheinlich daran dass die
studie überwiegend in brasilien und
südafrika gemacht wurden und daher
versuchen sie mal alte menschen zu
finden die noch in der lage sind an der
studie teilzunehmen dass die
bevölkerungen während die beiden studien
erhebliche anteile auch us amerikaner
europäer und agenten jahr haben also als
etwas ältere bevölkerung stammen
und weil man es nicht weiß hat die stiko
davon abgeraten diesen impfstoff in
höherem alter zu verwenden
die zulassung macht diese grenze nicht
die überlegung das vielleicht bei
jüngeren mit schwächerem insel stehen er
auch weniger wirksam ist es richtig das
bild aber in gleicher weise auch für
andere auch wieder für die anderen
impfstoffe und umgekehrt waren durchaus
menschen mit vorerkrankungen in die
studie eingeschlossen und bei denen ist
eben keine sehr wesentlich andere
krankheit gefunden worden
so wie heuer generell ja wir haben in
deutschland wie wir sehen eine relativ
große diskussionen das merke ich auch
ein kommentar auf kommen hier in diesem
stream über diesen impfstoff das ist in
anderen ländern wo dieser impfstoff
geimpft wird nicht so zum beispiel in
großbritannien
und da berichtet uns unsere kollegin
diana zimmermann folgendes hier ist man
sehr stolz auf den eigenen impfstoff der
impfstoff von oxford astrazeneca ist
sehr gut transportierbar und lagerbar er
ist außerdem sehr günstig oder wird hier
an alt und jung tatsächlich
millionenfach verimpft jeder fünfte
brite hat inzwischen die erste dosis
bekommen und diese dosen werden
verabreicht entweder mit astrazeneca
oder mit pfizer und beide impfstoffe der
liegen und staaten von ende januar vor
zeigen die gleiche menge an
nebenwirkungen und zwar etwa drei bis
vier der geimpften von 1000 geimpften
zeigen leichte grippe erkrankungen keine
skandal nirgends also im vereinigten
königreich überhaupt keine aufregung um
gar nichts von professor thomas von der
ständigen impfkommission sind wir in
deutschland zu übervorsichtig und
vielleicht zu ekelig oder sind die
briten blauäugig in ihrem stolz darauf
dass sie diesen impfstoff gefunden haben
tja vielleicht sind wir da wirklich zu
übervorsichtig in großbritannien kriegt
man dass wir auch nicht innerhalb von
ein zwei tagen den termin beim arzt wenn
man da gerne hin möchte dass es hier
undenkbar dass man nicht eben am selben
tag auch ein termin beim hausarzt
bekommt und dann hat zuletzt spielt
vielleicht auch eine rolle dieser
impfstoff wurde in england entwickelt
der bei und nicht impfstoff wurde in
deutschland entwickelt und war traut
sich vielleicht mache ich vielleicht
doch jeweils im eigenen land mehr zu
auch wenn das nicht unbedingt rational
ist das ist werde prinz werde ich das
noch ergänzen jahren weil hinten die
angst vor dem neuen impfstoffe mit dem
ganzen neuen prinzip sind die edlen
stoffe der von astrazeneca beruht auf
einem impfstoff prinzip was bereits
erprobt war und von dem es bereits
andere impfstoffe gibt ja das ist doch
ein kommentaren habe ich hier auf
youtube von lotus hans der sagt es schon
lustig am anfang wollte keiner mrm rna
weil ja so neu und bla bla bla und jetzt
will keiner den konventionellen vector
impfstoff so jetzt habe ich hier fragen
zur im freien folge ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher ob sie die richtige
ansprechpartnerin sind weil sie da ja
eigentlich nicht involviert sind
ich versuche es mal zu stellen sie
können gerne sagen da kann ich nichts zu
sagen also annika fragt wenn ich mich
mit einem vector impfstoff gegen korona
impfen lasse also zum beispiel
astrazeneca kann ich mich irgendwann
auch nochmal mit einem m rna impfstoff
impfen lassen dass fragen wohl viele
zuschauerinnen im moment noch eine
schwierige frage ich würde jetzt sagen
voraus liegt ja in dem moment wo es
genug davon gibt dass man über zweit in
formen also eine erneute eben funk
nachdenken kann und man wird sicherlich
vorher studien dazu machen wollen
vielleicht wissen sie sich dann eine
studie beteiligen vielleicht möchten sie
abwarten gelaufen sind
aber man wird sehen wollen was das macht
vor allem hinsichtlich der
verträglichkeit aber muss sie jetzt auch
keinen grund warum das nicht gehen
sollte und was dann gucken gut
verträglich sind die dann und wie gut
nochmal aber im prinzip
warum sollte das nicht funktionieren
kann dann geht es hier eine frage genau
dazu kann man sich eigentlich aussuchen
mit welchem impfstoff man geimpft wird
von horst weiter auf youtube sind aber
auch viele andere interessiert daran ob
das überhaupt geht
nein kann man tatsächlich im moment
nicht und die grundlage darf
verordnungen beziehungsweise annette der
bundesländer die dann im prinzip
gesetzescharakter haben
die ständige impfkommission macht eine
entscheidung um die wird umgesetzt in
einen erlass der da sagt man kann es
sich nicht aussuchen ist zumindest in
meinem bundesland in niedersachsen so
groß glaube anderswo auch das leben die
etwa impfstoffe reserviert sind und
ausschließlich reserviert sind für
menschen über 65
während alle unter 65 im moment eben den
astra zeneca impfstoff angeboten
bekommen zu sein ist wirklich die
relativ schnell eine große zahl der hoch
priorisierten menschen so ist dieser
ansatz ja also es gab in berlin wohl
ausnahmen da bis zur dritten fälle die
jetzt kommt ab jetzt kann man sich nicht
mehr aussuchen in berlin konnte man das
in der zeit lang aussuchen welchem stoff
man haben möchte dass es jetzt erstmal
vorbei so ich habe jetzt noch zwei drei
detailfragen einmal von johnny b 91 auf
youtube wenn der impfstoff fast
ausschließlich in südamerika getestet
wurde kann es dann sein dass er bei uns
in europa gar nicht so wird weil hier
ein anderes klima herrscht ist das
möglich nein und ausschließlich in
südamerika naja stimmt auch ich hatte
vorhin gesagt dafür als manager
überwiegend ihn mit afrika und brasilien
aber das hat mit den klimabedingungen
hat die wirksamkeit wurden die tatsache
wie viele fälle aufgetreten sind wie
sich irgendwie in der bevölkerung
entwickelt die kanton waadt mit dem
klima zu tun haben
das sind die etwas anderen studien
umstände die ich vorhin zitiert habe
aber das virus der serotyp des virus und
nach allem was man weiß auf die art und
weise wie er sich in der bevölkerung
ausbreitet und sie krank
werden ist ja sehr vergleichbar so dann
gibt es noch mal eine frage zu den
nebenwirkungen beziehungsweise zu den
langzeitfolgen die dies möglicherweise
gibt von tamara auf facebook gibt es ein
risiko dass dieser impfstoff später eine
autoimmun erkrankung verursacht auch
eine schwierige frage das ist etwas was
man mit aller letzter sicherheit nicht
ausschließen kann
es gibt aber umgekehrt auch nicht was
das gericht
solche nebenwirkungen treten
dort räumten auf in die beobachtung
schon da mitleid kann man das nicht
sagen was eigentlich ist es nicht gut
wenn das in wahrheit genauso geschehen
nicht noch mal der impfstoff macht nicht
was mich in diesen im kontext einer
kurve erkrankung auch passiert so also
ist das bild schon eingefroren das heißt
ihre leitung sagte uns wir müssen uns
zum ende kommunisten zum ende kann aber
eine frage habe ich noch die ich auch
ganz interessant finde
von tom auf youtube warum darf mein
hausarzt denn nichts gegen korona impfen
kurzer zeit so viele menschen zu impfen
war etwas was man zu recht oder zu
unrecht
den hauptakt initialen zugetraut hat das
hat zu tun mit problemen der impfstoff
lagerung das hat damit zu tun dass alle
diese impfstoffe im moment in mehr dosen
verhältnissen daherkommen
das heißt eine solche fläche sind je
nach präparat 6 10 im stoßen die dann
innerhalb sehr kurzer zeit verimpft
werden müssen
die impfstoffe sind zum teil auf getraut
kaum noch transportiert ich das kann man
sich vorstellen wie so ein zoll
schlagsahne die versicherung schüttelt
und dann hat man gesagt um das wirklich
schnell in großer zahl hinzukriegen
brauchen seine andere logistik als das
was eine haut ab fragt sich leisten kann
die ja immerhin auch noch alle anderen
menschen versorgen und alle anderen
impfungen leisten
mit dem jetzt aber so ist
eine kleine korrektur habe ich jetzt
noch von einer zuschauerin die schreibt
uns die iris auf facebook gestern konnte
man sich in berlin noch aussuchen mit
was man sich impfen lässt man kann sich
das impfzentrum aussuchen in dem er
bestimmte stoffe impft wird auch heute
gegen die terminvereinbarung noch nach
wunsch nach unseren informationen wird
das aber endlich sein und sich ändern
weil dann nur noch der astra zeneca
impfstoff für 18 bis 64 jährige verimpft
werden soll
frau professor ich danke irgendwas ich
danke ihnen dass sie sich so viel zeit
genommen haben heute abend alles zu
beantworten das sind wie immer noch
fragen offen aber ich glaube ganz bis
zum schluss kann man dieses schwierige
thema eh nicht durch exerzieren wir
bleiben auf jeden fall weiter im
gespräch und ich dann bedanke mich bis
hierhin bei ihnen und aller welt einen
schönen abend ebenso und ich sagen auch
danke für eure kommentare und fragen wie
gesagt es sind viele offen aber das ist
eben das problem was wir gerade mit
diesen impfstoffen haben viele fragen
werden sich erst in den nächsten monaten
und jahren schlussendlich klären aber
sicher ist jetzt schon da ist sich die
wissenschaft eben ziemlich sicher dass
die impfstoffe wirken und auch helfen
werden von daher hoffe ich dass wir ein
bisschen auch auf skepsis ausräumen
konnten auch wenn wir sie natürlich
teilen und wichtig finden und in diesem
sinne verabschiede ich mich für heute
und sagt bis zum nächsten mal macht's
gut
und tschüss
[Musik]